you had your wedding this summer is that
now canceled I did yeah yeah it is
indefinitely postponed we actually got
married anyway we got married in the
backyard okay how does it feel to be a
married woman it's really wonderful Alex
he's my best friend and I wasn't one of
those people who grew up planning their
wedding
I just wanted to marry my best friend so
I got to do that I'm very happy
and something else Rachel and fans can
be happy about that woman has been
renewed for a second season what hasn't
meant for you to take this role that's
so dynamic you're so rarely get to play
so many facets of a single character
Alice oh thank you disappointing me you
realize the more people we abduct the
more we risk exposure and you realize
none of this is real right I just have
so much fun with her and and they give
me free rein to kind of do do whatever I
want
suckers and now that Alice knows how to
kill her twin sister bat woman will she
actually ever do it I care about killing
that twin sister relationship is really
the crux of both there are storylines
they are equally and evenly matched in
every way they are genetically identical
you know they can't ever cross the line
and really destroy the other one because
they they love each other at the end of
the day